Artemis is NASA's plan to go back to the moon,...
...and Snoopy is to be the zero gravity indicator.
A zero G or zero gravity indicator demonstrates the moment...
...that the crew and the spacecraft reach weightlessness.
Snoopy is about to take his first trip around the moon.
The relationship with NASA and Snoopy goes back about 50 years...
...since the Apollo days.
He was the face of the safety campaign,...
...the icon for NASA's culture of safety and mission success.
So NASA and Peanuts have a Space Act Agreement...
...and we collaborate together on STEM content...
...and we really were excited when it was decided...
...that Snoopy would be the zero gravity indicator on Artemis 1.
We wanted to go all-out so we created a custom Snoopy...
...and the spacesuit is actually made out of material...
...worn by the NASA astronauts.
Everything was done with extreme detail.
They cut patterns for his suit, even how his collar worked...
...and how the NASA meatball logo looked.
We're very excited.
I'm personally very excited.
I can't contain the excitement I am feeling about this day.
Snoopy is going farther in space than he's ever been before.
This is a day that we've all been waiting for.
It's fantastic.